All right. Unit 4 homework time.
We are going to be adding user accounts, and there is going to be three parts to this..
The first part is going to be registration with a valid cookie.
Let's take a look at my working solution online and show you what I'm expecting.
So here we are in my form. It's at \signup.
This is the same form we used in unit 2, and it has the same validation.
If I type in some junk or forget to validate my passwords, I get an error message.
If I were to type in valid data and hit submit,
it takes me to a welcome page.
Notice this time there is no user in the welcome. That's because it set a cookie.
What that did is registered my user, I did the whole password hashing salting thing.
It's hard for us to test that, but what we can test is that after we log in,
the page we get redirected to should have the user name in it, and we should have a cookie.
I've installed this edit this cookie extension in Chrome, which is really handy for this sort of thing,
to let me view a cookie, and we can see we have a cookie named userID.
It's value is 2001 pipe and then a hash, which should look familiar from this lesson.
If I were to change this to a different user ID and then reload this welcome page,
it would redirect me to the signup page, because the cookie is no longer valid.
That is the first part of this homework--implement this signup page,
have a form that still checks for errors like unit 2,
and then if the user registers it redirects you to the welcome page.
If the user already exists, it should give an error that says that user already exists.
Okay, when you're done with that, submit the URL with that behavior here,
and we will check it.
Okay. Good luck.
We'll included, of course, more detailed description in the text description of this homework.
All of those form values and the form names and stuff that we'll be testing will be clear.
Okay. Good luck.